let's write one hundred and thirteen
point nine percent as a decimal so
percent this symbol right over here
literally means per hundred so this is
the same thing as one hundred and
thirteen point nine per hundred which is
thirteen point nine divided by divided
by one hundred so essentially if we want
to write this as a decimal we just take
one hundred thirteen point nine and we
divided by a hundred and to do that one
hundred thirteen point nine divided by a
hundred if you divide by ten you move
the decimal once to the left if you
divide by a hundred you're moving the
decimal twice to the left if we're doing
it by a thousand we would go to the left
once more ten thousand each time you
divide by ten you'd go one step to the
left which hopefully makes sense if you
were to multiply by ten we would be
moving the decimal over to the right and
there are other videos that go into far
more depth and the intuition behind that
but anyway we're dividing a hundred
thirteen point nine by a hundred so move
the decimal two spaces to the right to
the left so the decimal will end up
right over here so this will be equal to
one point one three nine and we are done